the Joe Rogan experience do you know
studio 35 and you know [ __ ] I mean
you know yes holy [ __ ] man [ __ ] I was
just there there week what's crazy you
were you there we go
wait so you know that theater fantastic
[ __ ] theater I I always know Columbus
as that theater as that Street and then
we actually went into the city and I was
like they built a whole city around that
little corner and [ __ ] that like that's
been here forever did you know and you
must know Columbus is the swinger
capital of the United States of America
what misses a lot of things we were
staying there we want to do a show at
Studio 35 like years ago for the first
time like almost ten years ago we've
known these cats some great people and
they put us up in a house and like you
know the house was like neatly appointed
but nobody lived there like even as an
air B&B it was just like this is very
clean and [ __ ] and so when we got back
to the place they're like you like the
house and we were like yeah it's nice
man is in the middle of the woods away
from everything down a beaten path and
[ __ ] and we were like yeah it's nice to
know like it's the swinger house and I'm
like what do you mean I feel like that's
the house where the swingers go to [ __ ]
should they're like didn't you notice
all the boxes of tissues and I realized
that a [ __ ] room had a box of tissues
in the corner so it's this way and I was
like why would that happen here in
Columbus Ohio and they were like
Columbus Ohio is the swinger capital of
the United States you should go back
with a black light and check it all out
[ __ ] find out what's happening
where the splatters are I think I think
I remember that night sleeping on my
jacket you know I got my own come to
deal with yeah have you ever heard that
was that horseshoe that's where hustler
started was in Columbus
Thomas Larry Larry Flynt started
Columbus is the birth of a lot of
[ __ ] places that's what he said you
open up the door for Jaime
he's gonna see theories that go here
this would change the whole show so
Columbus is this hidden jewel it's a
great place it is really really a great
place I love it but there it's a great
[ __ ] theatre man I have yet to see
any proof of swinger activity myself I
recall
my 2009 Comedy Central special at the
was a spike spike TV special at the time
at the southern theater in Columbus yeah
with a good crowd [ __ ] yeah it's great I
love Columbus I love it
last time I was there was like what year
and a half ago
yeah September if they're shot in star
oh yeah about a year they gave me for us
last night
so that's awesome two shows for his
really lovely people
[Applause]